there was always speculation of you and
emma being something and i feel like it
pops up every couple of years
what do you make of that
[Music]
so we have hit movies theme parks talks
of a series now we have a flagship store
tell me about this because i've been to
like there's the store in the universal
studios i've been to the one in king's
cross so
what is like the difference what is this
store exactly well that's the beauty of
it is i don't think we really know
quite yet but i i sort of see it as like
an international clubhouse
or for me personally it's like a step
back into my
childhood and to be honest with you when
i heard about how
ambitious they were with what they were
trying to do with the store i thought
you're never going to be able to pull
that off but alas i am here
proved wrong once again at the creations
and inventiveness of these various
different
parks it feels like a home like a like a
potter home again i don't want to say
the name potter again but that's how it
feels so it's really exciting to know
that
they've invested in this which i'm sure
over the next
well it's been two decades since we made
the first film i'm sure in the next two
decades
this will be a really safe lovely
positive great place to
to go visit so i'm i'm excited as i say
you're you're saying you're saying
potter
potter i know you caught me out there
i saw recently that you went back and
watched the movie
the first movie which is on a 20-year
anniversary which is insane
um you watch it for the first time in
like 10 years
god look at him radcliffe looks about
fine now ah good lord
all right keep it together keep it
together it was the first time that i've
ever watched it
thoroughly as far as like actually i
mean i remember the premieres but i
remember just
kids booing me and thinking that i was a
uh
assad in real life which which
subsequently meant i was doing a good
job but um
it's been a long time about getting
pretty teary and going like
wow that's my childhood or at least the
start of a lot of um
start of an adventure that here we are
20 years later still talking about it
there was always speculation of you and
emma being something and i feel like it
pops up every couple of years
what do you make of that
listen that's it i mean if
we are something if that makes any sense
as far as we've been very close for a
long time
and i adore her i think she's fantastic
and hopefully she returns the compliment
but as far as the romantic side of it i
think that's a slytherin
gryffindor thing rather than a tom and
emma thing but
i absolutely think the world of her and
i think being part of what we've all
been
part of but for her to be kind of the
only girl certainly the youngest
one on set to grow up with what she had
to
grow up with was was incredibly exciting
and listen you're going to get me teary
now
no but i i think that she's a fantastic
influence
on the world when was the last time that
the gang was
all together and is there a plan to make
that happen soon we do stay in touch
quite frequently really or not so um
it's nice that we're always in four
different corners of the earth and yet
when we catch up it feels like
yesterday that this was all going on and
it's really touching and sweet i think
that like daniel rupert and emma
especially they gave
so much of their lives to the films and
to the
potter universe if you will and yet all
three of them are still equally
proud and amazed really as i am as we
all are amazed at how
much positivity has come off the back of
the films and the fan clubs and the uh
the potterverse or whatever
whatever it goes in so um i know that i
can
speak for all of them when i say that
we're all very proud
of what we did and we're very excited
about all these new
ventures i think one of the uh saving
graces of us as a family is that we all
grew up with it
and we're still growing up with it and
we're still exploring different parts of
our own lives i know emma's
well all of the cast have got their own
ventures going on whether it's
a baby right rupert's a dad i was like
what
that was amazing and it's so nice to see
that and it's nice to see
emma spread her wings into so many
different other entities other than
acting because she's
incredible in many different other
factions and then yeah just sort of
really seeing what happens with their
life really post poster i can speak for
all of them when i say
we are all silently and secretly amazed
and
very grateful for all of the uh support
and magic excuse the pun that's that's
happened since we left
just looking ahead to the future there's
been so much talk about a tv
series and i'm just curious your
thoughts if malfoy is called upon would
you be interested in
in joining i don't know what's happening
i'm actually writing it
good tell you that no i'm not writing
that's true
i uh this is the first i've heard of it
today in fact
uh a part of the series i doubt it
highly
listen the harry potter flame is not
gonna burn out anytime soon so
it wouldn't surprise me whatever way it
is it's beautiful head next time but yes
obviously if you're asking me do i feel
slightly possessive over the character
of draco abso bloody lutely
or lucius or whatever it may be gonna
give me the chance
the hair will go back to blonde but
until then i'll just celebrate what
we've done so far you know i talk to a
lot of people that are part of these
like major franchises and they go
some of them like they don't really they
kind of try to distance themselves
and i just love how like immersed you
are in the harry potter universe still
did you ever go through that journey of
being like i
kind of want to be like not completely
associated with this
and what brought you back what brought
you back into the fandom i'm lucky
enough
uh that i live a really a very normal
life
i walk my dog in the park every day and
yes yes every day there's always some
random teenager running up to me
and whatnot but i'm um not only am i
very happy and proud to be part of it
but also it's really um it's the fandom
i think
that sort of kept me there it's uh
they've sort of become my family
in a weird twisted way and i've seen so
much
positivity come off the back of not
necessarily the books or the films
or the tours but just just the sort of
the whole
the whole thing really i found um
there's a really
really large global community
of people that enjoy potter
potter rather and also
lovely caring funny kind
people and that's the kind of the
people's i like
and i think the new york store is just
another opportunity for people
of that nature to get together really
and sort of celebrate
life even if they are muggles or
ravenclaws or hufflepuffs we're
accepting
um on that note ashley what how stephen
i'm actually a slytherin i got sorted
into slytherin on pottermore and i
always felt like i was a slytherin so
i'm gonna need to see some sort of
certification of that
i do have it you know what i had the
slytherin sweatshirt
from the store and i dried it and it it
it got this big i was like oh no
well that's the other reason why i'm so
excited about all of these different
ventures is that i'm um
i get to go on a supermarket sweep and
grab as much
slytherin swag to decorate my office
with so that's the bonus
didn't you get sorted into hufflepuff
let's not go there
did you really know no i did not i did
not i tried 24 times and eventually i
got the one i wanted no i i've tried
twice
um first time was genuinely gryffindor
um which took me years to get over and
then uh
and then i did do it this this year last
year rather and
um very um smugly my family were all
hufflepuffs i had i think
three of the four of them were all
hufflepuffs very disappointed with them
but i actually got slytherin so i was
quite smug about that and still
am clearly
[Music]